ukraine's resistance is getting a big
boost from the response of president
vladimir zielinski the former actor is
aspiring confidence in his troops while
securing weapons money and strategic
help from the country's many allies he
told russian soldiers this morning don't
trust your propaganda just save your
lives and leave holly williams looks at
zelinski's leadership in the face of
massive danger
with his country in crisis
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski is
the very definition of leading from the
front
sharing videos of himself on the street
to reassure his people that he's still
in the country
he's braving russian missiles and
airstrikes and telling ukrainians you
are strong you are unbroken
he reportedly turned down a u.s offer to
help him evacuate saying i need
ammunition not a ride
president zielenski has become an
inspiration for those protesting this
invasion around the world and for the
ukrainian resistance which is now in
full swing across this country we've
seen volunteers who've taken up arms
while others are making molotov
cocktails including this group of women
who've set up an assembly line
online videos show ordinary ukrainians
accosting russian troops
take these seeds spit this woman at a
soldier so flowers will grow when you
die here
but there are also grave fears for
president zielinski's safety he says he
and his young family are russia's top
targets and during this defiant speech
on the weekend the translator broke down
in tears
again
ukraine is fighting for its very
existence led by a man who's put himself
in the firing line for cbs morning's
holly williams